la neisseria vienen a distribuir ayuda
humanitaria a personas que han decidido
quedarse
e intentar evacuar a quienes quieren
irse la mayoría son mayores pensionados
y sin medios para huir como este grupo
que vive en un centro cultural del isi
shanks cada rincón se ha convertido en
una casa provisional
esta abuela vive en el sótano junto con
algunos familiares
ella dice que qué hace en su vida desde
hace 80 días cocinan rezan limpian
la pareja tiene prisa les preocupa que
solo tienen un par de horas antes de que
se recrudezcan los ataques en la
carretera de acceso a visitantes es en
lo alto de la montaña y se ve dos nietos
en la parte baja lo podemos ver de esta
aquí esa dirección es sheraton yesca
en severo dones las calles están
abandonadas las fuerzas rusa la acedia
la lucha por controlarla es crucial en
la lucha por la región del donbass
muchos no tienen otra opción que
sobrevivir de la ayuda que les llega
necesitamos que esta guerra se acabe tan
pronto como sea posible si nos pueden
ayudar con algo no tenemos carne papas
cebollas zanahorias
hubiera yo en este colegio junto con 16
personas incluido una pequeña
desde hace semana no tienen electricidad
agua en internet
ellos atacan en esta dirección y los
otros devuelven usted puede ver que la
escuela tiene heridas necesitamos
cocinar afuera no tenemos otra opción
tenemos que comer tú
esta gente está traumatizada todavía se
puede hablar con algunos de ellos pero
más de la mitad no entienden qué pasa
esto sucede porque viven en sótanos y
rodeados por el miedo castellana se
siente extraño
estamos en la parte final de
severodonezk y nos dicen que aquí las
tropas rusas están a 1.7 kilómetros
hacia esta dirección y 4 hacia esta
dirección ayer una gran batalla y aquí
todos dicen que tienen bastante miedo
cada día que pasa la vida es más difícil
el edificio aludir ha sido atacado como
muchos ella asegura que al menos el 40
por ciento de los residentes no se han
ido la mayoría son jubilados no hay
mucho mire esto no hay nada es agua
vamos a tomar té y nada más que podemos
hacer
como el esquí putin necesitan reunirse y
negociar porque la gente se siente
abandonada completamente tenemos mucha
gente mayor
2000 a quisiera irse si la situación se
complica aún más pero posiblemente ya es
demasiado tarde de ser gay también que
no habrá otra oportunidad de regresar
las fuerzas rusas están cada vez más
cerca y la batalla se recrudece